[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt
die sowohl süß
ja aber das ist auch gut so eine menge
geschafft haben
ist auch egal meine liebe freunde ich
darf euch hier heute ich hier ich
darf euch heute auf jeden fall recht
herzlich willkommen heißt es einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca um meine
lieben freunde wir hatten noch nie so
wenig vor für eine
weil wir dass er trotz mini machen
müssen
ich muss quarz holen heute
ja eigentlich schon die sache ist
allerdings dass ich noch eine menge
quasi meine strang für das benötige denn
ich habe ja noch immer nicht das obere
stockwerk eingerichtet unten haben wir
zwar schon die dings gebaut wir haben
schon die küche gebaut wir haben schon
das kleine esszimmer gebaut wir haben
allerdings hier oben noch nichts gebaut
und hier noch nichts gebaut und das
wollte ich eigentlich heute machen
jedoch benötigen wir eine menge quad und
ich denke dass ich es dann doch nicht
schaffen werde mit der strand ist wenn
auch heute weil wir auch noch schnee
benötigen also ein paar dinge müssen auf
jeden fall noch getan werden von daher
heute wieder eine komplette letzte
episode auf die ich mich jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz vorbereitet nur wenige minuten
später so freunde wir sind fertig
ausgerüstet das hat sich jetzt glaube
ich nicht gelohnt dafür eine timeline zu
beenden weil es jetzt nicht so
sonderlich lang gedauert hat das einzige
was ich gemacht habe war dass ich mir
noch die wir pilz route mitgenommen
haben so dass wir mit unserer sandra
entspannt über die lava reiten können
und ich habe mir selbstverständlich noch
einige gold stiefel angezogen noch so
ein bisschen essentials mitgenommen
allerdings
befinden wir uns wieder am netz
und euch jetzt zumindest meine ganz
kurze time netz wie ich auf meiner
sandra wir hier unten noch immer auf
mich wartet zurück zu unserer quarz farm
laufe
so da sind wir jetzt auch schon hier
vorne angekommen sondern wartet mal ganz
kurz hier unten
ja ich weiß leider anders wird sie
abhauen die sache ist jetzt allerdings
dass wir uns wieder hier in die richtung
bewegen wir sind ja als sechsmal dem
netter waren auch hier lang gelaufen
jedoch habe ich jetzt einen etwas
anderen planen denn letztes mal sind wir
so vorgegangen dass wir dann hier daran
vorbeigelaufen sind heute möchte ich
allerdings so vorgehen dass ich wirklich
durch diese festung hier durchlaufe denn
wir benötigen ja auch noch einige lohnen
routen denn ich habe ja mal einen plan
für die letzte folge minecraft mit luca
ein bisschen geändert ich wollte
eigentlich in der letzten folge noch mal
ein bisschen was machen in die richtung
hey wir machen alles was dieses projekt
ausgemacht hat noch mal in einer großen
xxl folge jedoch habe ich mir dann
gedacht vielleicht macht es auch sinn
einfach ins ende zu gehen also in die
andere minecraft welt und das ganze
spiel durchzuspielen wir haben ja auf
jeden fall direkt lohnen am start ich
weiß nicht woher das bonner ist ich sehe
auch fast gar nichts der ist ja auch
direkt wieder fast runtergefallen
allerdings haben wir vorne auch schon
direkt eine kiste ich bin gespannt was
ihr drin ist alles was von irgendeiner
seite hier lohnen auf jeden fall um
kommt allerdings könne die direkt
attackieren sagt direkt drauf und
dreimal schlafen dann haben wir sehr
lohnen routen hat die jetzt noch nichts
allerdings haben wir hier drinnen
erstmal goldbarren reisen ein feuerzeug
und ein goldschmied das benötigen wir
nicht das feuerzeug ist auf jeden fall
wichtig falls wir hier verloren gehen
sollten oder falls unser netter portal
ausgehen sollte wir sind jetzt
allerdings hier schon wieder raus die
sache ist auch dass ich eigentlich
aufgrund von quad sie hingegangen bin
von daher konzentrieren wir uns darauf
wenn ich allerdings irgendwo natürlich
lohnenswert werde ich attackieren werde
nicht zurückschrecken und werde auf
jeden fall versuchen die eine oder
andere lohn route mit abzustauben hier
vorne haben wir auf jeden fall ratsam
start und genau dafür habe ich auch
meine glück spitzhacke mitgenommen die
hat zwar nur glück eins meine glück
dreispitz gewisse ja die ist leider
ziemlich kaputt ich möchte die wir noch
reparieren allerdings
weiß ich
wir haben einen gast und wir haben hier
nur das glücklich wäre es jetzt direkt
mit den usa aufnehmen ich weiß es dieser
stark sind allerdings bin ich auch stark
und ich bin stabil
ich bin ein stabiler spieler hier oben
befinden sich auf jeden fall ein paar
lohnen die werde ich jetzt auf jeden
fall erstmal attackieren so dass ich von
runter soll sehr gut so dass ich von
denen hoffentlich vielleicht ein paar
lohnen routen bekommen das ganze feiert
erst mal relativ egal ich habe eine
ziemlich starke rüstung gerade an dies
auf jeden fall auch tot und
keine lohn route gedroppt also wir haben
leider wirklich bisher nichts davon
bekommen ich werde zu oft instant mal
wieder runter gehen und mich jetzt aber
auch auf das konzentrieren hier vorne
haben wir nämlich auch noch eine kleine
quarzader am start
[Musik]
das kannst du dir wirklich nicht
ausdenken ich hatte alle sachen dabei
ich hatte nur eine dia spitze ich hatte
meinen verzaubertes die erschwert ich
hatte meine komplette rüstung an und das
problem ist dass ich ja nicht mal weiß
wie ich da hinkommen soll weil ich meine
wir pilz angelruten situation damit
hatte
was soll die scheiße die keinen solchen
moment hat man gar keinen bock apples
habe ich auf jeden fall luca positiv
sehen ich darf auf jeden fall keine zeit
verlieren ich nehme jetzt mal eine angel
und werdet ihr jetzt einfach mal hierhin
packen und ihren dings dann bekomme ich
nämlich eine wie pilze route und werde
mich jetzt auch ein bisschen ausrüster
ich hab hier auf jeden fall noch diamant
stiefel ich hab noch dies am start ich
glaube auch dass ich hier vorne in
meinem raum unten ja auch noch ein
bisschen rüstung am start habe nämlich
hier und hier dann kann ich das jetzt
nämlich auch nochmal anziehen perfekt
sohn im moment so dass ein mal eben
anziehen und das anziehen perfekt hat
überhaupt keine haltbarkeit ich weiß
dass ich gesagt habe dass ich in diesem
projekt kein fleisch essen werde
allerdings habe ich gerade keine anderen
möglichkeiten außer dass ich mir jetzt
hier ein bisschen schweinefleisch auf
jeden fall beraten meine neffen ich weiß
nicht was ich sonst machen soll ich weiß
nicht wie ich sonst an essen kommen soll
jetzt innerhalb von kürzester zeit weil
die sache ist ja dass meine items nach
ein paar minuten verschwinden wenn ich
die nicht einsammeln von daher muss ich
mich jetzt wirklich krass beeilen und
jetzt mal ganz fix eben kurz wieder hier
ein bisschen fleisch rausholen so dass
ich zumindest ein bisschen was zu essen
mitnehmen kann wenn ich jetzt in die
hölle gehe ich habe mich jetzt grob
ausgerüstet ich habe mit eisen schwert
gemachten eisen spitzhacke ich habe noch
einen anderen bogen mitgenommen den ich
noch hatte der hatte irgendwie nur
stärke keine ahnung irgendwie was er hat
schild hier vorne mal ein portal perfekt
ich habe ein bisschen stocker
mitgenommen 20 gebratene schweinefleisch
hab ich ne barack und ich habe auch
einen satten ohne pilze route von daher
hoffe ich dass ich jetzt hier irgendwo
eine dings finde so eine kleine sandra
mit der ich eventuell direkt rüber
fahren kann mehr sie über das wasser
halten kann das wäre perfekt dass wir
auf jeden fall die super super lösung
die sache ist allerdings dass ich die
nächste dort hinten befindet wo man in
gott perfekt wir haben hier vorne auf
jeden fall noch eine am start und können
uns jetzt instant in die richtung da
hinten bewegen ich hoffe so sehr dass
die sache noch da sind wir packen unsere
zweite song recht einfach mal in dem
loch wo mein gott es geht hier direkt
wieder attackiert ich höre doch schon
wieder irgendein gas ist wieder extrem
sauer auf mich ich habe keine ahnung
warum ich habe euch nichts getan hat so
nicht jetzt direkt hier lang meine
lieben freunde direkt den gleichen weg
wieder hoch ich weiß zwar nicht wo ich
das paar zwei hin gefunden habe es war
halt irgendwo an sondern decke aber ich
weiß nicht mehr genau an welcher decke
oder wie ich da hingekommen bin hier
vorn bin ich auch noch mal hoch dann oh
mein gott sind hier viele von den teilen
geformt hat das kann doch nicht sein das
kann doch nicht wahr sein wie viele sind
an ihrem sport ich habe schon wieder nur
noch voll wie
kann das denn sein dass sie schon wieder
so viele von ihnen gewohnt sind alter
ich habe drei herzen wie geht das
[Musik]
wie geht das
die kommen aus allen ecken ich bin im
krieg ich wollte einfach nur hin und ein
bisschen quads und auf einmal geht sie
komplett ab ja ich wollte ein bisschen
zu
[Musik]
hier sehe ich den hierdurch
das ist ja überhaupt jana
[Musik]
alter
wie viele sind hier
wie viele sind hier und warum kann ich
da plötzlich durch gucken
warum kann ich hier durch gucken was ist
hier los ich brauche nur meine items ich
will nicht mit euch kämpfen ich will die
lohn routen ja aber ich will eigentlich
gerade primär zu meinen items ist er
hinter der front durch dirk und ich weiß
es nicht ich sehe gar nichts mehr da
vorne ein kleiner 2 was ist denn hier
los ich will einfach nur meine items
zurück haben und jetzt kommen wir von
allen seiten welche von allen seiten
werde ich hier wieder attackiert wir
vorne haben wir noch eine kiste da ist
nur gold drin und ein bisschen eisen
allerdings muss ich mir jetzt wirklich
prioritäten setzen ich muss die jetzt
töten und muss danach meine items
zurückkriegen der ist tot und er hier
vorne ist auch tot ok perfekt ich glaube
wir haben alle getötet noch mal ganz
schnell jedem schweinefleisch sind jetzt
da sind meine absolut ok zwar direkt
hier vorne die items sind noch nicht
dies bei und oh mein gott es sind zwar
eine menge level weg ich habe hier nur
noch zehn level aber das ist mir gerade
wirklich scheißegal ich setze jetzt
erstmal crafting table hin und werd mir
dann eine kiste machen wo ich die
wichtigsten sachen reinpacken werde so
dass ich hier nicht mit allen sachen
rumlaufen muss
[Musik]
warum greift nämlich denn an ich habe
ihm sogar extra an gold hingeworfen
jetzt bin ich hier mit allen auf
kriegsfuß oder was reif für mich die
anderen jetzt auch an
die machen nichts da unten ist auf jeden
fall meine glück spitzhacke habe ich
gehe jetzt mal ganz kurz bevor ich es
vergesse oh mein gott leute ich wollte
eigentlich nur entspannt hierhin und ein
bisschen quatsch abbauen und dann bin
ich mich daher habe ich mich das
perfekte ja direkt auch noch lava hier
rein bei dem quatsch was ich gerade
abgebaut habe was soll denn diese
scheiße kann der nutzer nicht einmal auf
meiner seite sein ein einziges mal das
ist doch nicht zu viel verlangt
die ganze zeit
es ist einfach keine pause da ich werde
die ganze zeit attackiert von diesen
idioten ich werde mein schweinefleisch
jetzt auch noch mal hier in die kiste
reinpacken das benötige ich ja definitiv
wird erst mal nicht mehr ich habe genug
brot am start die spektrale packe ich
mal auch rein das feuerzeug benötige ich
nicht und die anderen sachen habe ich
hier auf jeden fall im inventar den
stärke 2 bogen packe ich auch noch rein
und die fackel nämlich noch hier unten
hin und jetzt meine lieben freunde
konzentrieren wir uns wieder auf fahrt
[Musik]
warum ist denn hier in ruhe min
dann bin ich gerade dumm
nägler mach dein ding aber ich frage
mich trotzdem warum hier plötzlich in
münchen in der hülle einfach rum läuft
ja meine lieben freunde ich habe gerade
20 minuten lang schwarz gefahren ich
habe schon den einen quartz dings hier
zu 60 grad gemacht und jetzt habe ich
insgesamt hier fast 26 quartz
tatsächlich farben können der hölle ich
glaube dass das ausreichen sollte für
das was ich noch vorhabe in der
strandhaus wetter ich musste mich ein
bisschen was mit quad säule noch machen
noch ein bisschen was mit quarz stufen
das problem gerade jetzt nur dass ich
mich verlaufen habe
also noch mal eine ganz kurze time netz
wie ich den weg nach hause versuche zu
finden
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde wir befinden uns
wieder in meiner schönen kleinen süßen
minecraft die sonne geht dahin die
perfekt auf und an der stelle meine
lieben freunde würde ich dann das
heutige video auch beenden auch wenn es
heute ein bisschen drunter und drüber
ging ich hatte keinen richtigen plan ich
wusste nur dass ich eine menge quads auf
jeden fall benötige für meine strandhaus
villa hoffe ich das euch dennoch
gefallen hat in der nächsten folge
werden wir auf jeden fall deutlich
vorankommen wir werden die strandhaus
villa hoffentlich fertig bauen ich hoffe
mal dass ich das hinkriege ich habe
schon ne menge notizen gemacht wie ich
das ganze machen möchte eine menge
skizzen von da her schaltet auch auf
jeden fall nicht übermorgen wieder ein
da kommen nämlich ebay fails ich merke
wie gut durch die serie wieder gefällt
sondern am sonntag werden wir die
strandvilla fertig beim also meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefällt hat
das kann einen daumen hoch und ein video
her da abonnieren einen kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr die neue folge
minecraft blut oder nicht verpassen
wollt wir sehen uns sonntag wieder
chelsea
[Musik]